in the last few days president Trump
actual photo has shaken up his legal
team
Ty Cobb is out presumably to get back to
his cranberry bog Trump's bringing in
impeachment expert Emmett flood not
because he's worried or anything but
because it always pays to have flood
insurance
who says conservatives can't do cavity
and finally as the piece de resistance
button English Trump has hired personal
lawyer America's Mayor Rudy Giuliani who
in spite of what I have speculated in
the past is not an enchanted
jack-o'-lantern by bad I'm sorry now
Rudy brings a bold new strategy to
Trump's legal defense take this alleged
stormy Daniels hush money story I'm sick
of this there's nothing there Donald
Trump made it very clear last month when
it came to the payment he knew nothing
about it
[Music]
yeah on airplanes Trump says no to two
things hush money payments and agreeing
to help people off the plane in the
event of an emergency
yet somehow there are still questions so
Trump sent his boy Rudy on hannity last
night to answer the question once and
for all paying some stormy Daniels woman
130,000 I mean which is gonna turn out
to be perfectly legal they funneled it
through the law firm funnel throw offer
him and the president repaid it oh I
didn't know that he did yeah oh of
course you didn't know that Sean because
you're not Trump's lawyer yet give it a
week yes Rudy the president's lawyer
just said that Trump did pay Daniels and
knew about it that's some Giuliani style
straight talk which comes with its fair
share of spittle and pastrami chunks Oh
Julia hey
when you say it you could smell it right
very vivid very vivid don't like justice
the Fleck of justice right there
Giuliani is embarking on a bold new
strategy
don't deny the thing don't excuse the
thing just say the thing finally we're
done dancing around these snowflakes
worried about laws and/or consequences
who cares about the PC police or the
regular police Rudy is the just say the
thing expert remember when the White
House insisted that Trump's travel ban
wasn't a quote Muslim ban they did a lot
of bobbin and Weavin Rudy don't play
that he just goes on TV and he says the
thing so right when he first announced
that he said Muslim ban he called me up
he said put a commission together show
me the right way to do it legally that's
it that's the kind of reason and that's
so rock-solid it ends up being directly
quoted in a judge's court ruling against
you I love just say the thing no more
excuses we can just come clean with no
consequences hey hey Fitbit I've never
hit 10,000 steps I tell you around my
dog's foot every day and slap you on at
the last minute so I can get those sweet
sweet fireworks sorry I just said that
thing and before you could say won't
Donald Trump get in trouble for just
saying the thing ask yourself when has
that ever happened before
it must not be illegal you must be
confused you know what let me illuminate
this for you with my trusty gas lights
was Donald Trump telling the truth was
Rudy telling the truth is having your
own lawyer and criminate you on TV and
good strategy because it seems stupid
stupid like a fox
which means it's smart which means it's
not stupid you get it you're smart you
watch so much TV Donald Trump paid off
stormy Daniels to help his campaign is
that illegal if you say it on TV it
can't be a crook
hey let's all confess to something on
three one two oh you just said this
that's okay you're not confessing a
crime you're just saying the thing the
light washes it away
Gaslight is the best disinfectant
go get them Rudy you truly are the
lawyer Donald Trump deserve
[Music]